everybody poops yet some of us are still
uncomfortable to talk about it and find
it gross well what goes in must come out
so you should pay attention to your poop
because it can really tell you a lot
about your gut health how efficient it
is in absorbing nutrients and eliminate
waste our faeces is mainly made out of
75 water and 25 solid matter consisting
of dead and living bacteria indigestible
food and inorganic substances so
typically it takes about three days for
food to pass through your system
but when food passes through your system
either too quickly or too slowly it can
affect the shape texture color and
consistency of your stool
so what and how you eat can in fact
affect your digestive system hence if
you change your diet you will also
notice that your poop could look and
smell different so let's have a look at
the different shapes and texture of poop
and what they actually mean
does your poop look like this separate
hot alarms like nuts or a lumpy sausage
shape if your stew looks like this hard
and dry and you find it really difficult
and painful to pass then you are
suffering from constipation on top of
that you might only have three or less
bowel movements per week this may be due
to dehydration a diet low in fiber lack
of exercise or perhaps you're taking a
medication that could also affect your
digestive health
does your poop look like this on a daily
basis
sausage shaped but with cracks around
the surface or
a smooth and soft snake shape well
congratulations this is where you want
to be you've reached pooping perfection
your diet is on point and you have a
strong digestion you're getting enough
water and fiber and your stews are
healthy everyone's bathroom habits are
different but the average is once every
day so
keep it up
and finally does your poop look like one
of these
soft flops with well-defined edges or
mushy stew with ragged edges looking
more like a pile than clear separate
stools or
watery and containing no solid pieces
well this is a sign of a weak guard or
diarrhea if your poops are soft blobs
this may be a sign of malabsorption of
nutrients excess gas in the gi tract or
a high fat concentration in your stool
if it's all in pieces this could be a
sign of food intolerance or allergy or
perhaps you might be experiencing a
stomach infection or you're under the
use of laxatives if your poop is loose
and watery and you have to go more than
three times in one day well that's
diarrhea this is an indicator that your
digestive system is rejecting something
and that can be linked to bacteria
parasites or viruses if you experience
diarrhea for an extended period of time
well you need to seek professional help
immediately because this could be linked
to another health issue so what does
your poop look like share with me in the
comments section below
by just making small dietary changes
this could help you build a stronger gut
increase nutrient absorption from the
food you consume and improve the good
gut bacteria and as a result this can
have a positive impact on your mood
energy levels and attitude
digestive issues are often caused by an
imbalance in the bacteria that live
naturally in our intestines our body
needs both pre and probiotics to keep
our immune system strong and to support
our overall gut health that is why i
take my pre and probiotic every day to
boost my gut health they're both
important and play different roles
probiotics are food or supplements that
contain life microorganisms meant to
maintain or improve the good bacteria in
our body
on the other hand prebiotics are a type
of fiber that the human body cannot
digest and they serve as food for
probiotics i've been consuming ours
cause a health drink every morning this
is a 100 natural supplement made in
japan and this has gone through a one
year fermentation using traditional
japanese methods hence this drink
provides a balanced nutrition combining
prebiotics probiotics as well as
postbiotics which is the byproduct of
the good bacteria all in this one bottle
to gain the maximum benefits i would
consume one serving of our scorsese
mixed with half a cup of water on an
empty stomach every morning to boost my
gut health and what i really love about
this is that it is made from over 100
different vegetables fruits and
plant-based ingredients including
seaweeds and mushrooms so this is really
delicious i've consumed this for almost
a year now and i've never felt the same
i don't experience constipation or
bloating as often as i used to and my
toilet experience has been very pleasant
so ever since i started paying attention
to my gut health i've seen improvement
on my mood energy level and also my skin
health so your overall well-being starts
from right here
do check out ars corso and use my promo
code joanna to get 10 off links are in
my description box below just one
serving every morning to improve your
digestion and gut health
our body is made up of 60 fluid and our
proof is made up of 75 fluid so how
important is water
drinking enough water is extremely
important to keep everything moving in
your digestive tract yep we know that we
should be drinking at least two to three
liters of water every day it sounds like
a lot but a simple trick is to drink one
glass once you're awake in the morning
and drink a glass of water before every
meal besides just drinking water there
are also other methods to increase your
water intake and stay hydrated so one of
it is to eat more foods high in water
content it is estimated that about 22 of
the water we ingest comes from our food
vegetables which have a high water
content include spinach
lettuce
bok choy asparagus
cabbage celery cauliflower cucumber and
zucchini fruits which are high in water
content include citrus grapefruit tomato
peach
strawberry blueberry watermelon honeydew
and bell pepper you want to also reduce
drinks that can cause dehydration such
as soda energy drink coffee tea and
alcohol these drinks contain diuretics
and can cause you to urinate more
frequently so instead of keeping you
hydrated drinking it too much can cause
dehydration to your body so remember to
consume them in moderation
[Music]
fiber is vital for healthy solid bowel
movements this is because dietary fiber
increases the size of your stools making
them softer and easier to pass so the
general recommendation for dietary fiber
intake is 25 grams for women and 38
grams for men daily set yourself a goal
to always fill half your plate with
vegetables every day to increase your
fiber intake if however you're telling
me that you know what i'm consuming more
than enough fiber yet i'm always bloated
and constipated well here's what you
need to know having too much fiber in
your diet can also cause bloating gas
and constipation this is especially
common for someone who is following a
vegan or a raw diet eating more than 70
grams of fiber a day can indeed cause
bloating and constipation so remember do
not overdo it how you go how frequently
you go and the appearance of your stool
can tell you a lot about your digestive
health and overall health so the next
time you're in the toilet don't just be
so quick to flush
take a look down the toilet bowl and
then check your poop paying attention to
your poop can help you build a stronger
gut check your organ functions and boost
nutrient absorption from the foods you
eat so remember to
take a peek
and don't forget to flush
well this video is full of [ __ ] but i
hope that you have found this video to
be super informative and that you will
click the like button and share this
video with your family and friends and
encourage them to
check their poop okay don't forget to
also hit the subscribe button if you
haven't yet done it and do check out a
lot more informative videos on my
youtube channel and i will see you in my
next video all the best